Hollywood actors emerged to virtue
signal from their mansions debate renews
over statues and Seattle's new republic
of weakness experiences some early
growing pins I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show today's show is
sponsored by expressvpn don't let others
track what you do keep yourself safe and
expressvpn dot-com slash men all righty
so it's been an interesting 24 hours and
it seems like the narrative is beginning
to shift a little bit and one of the
reasons the nerve is beginning to shift
is because everything that starts off as
a legitimate cause eventually becomes a
grift for a certain number of people and
that doesn't mean that the vast majority
of people who are involved in protesting
police brutality are not sincere I think
that they are sincere and I think
protesting police brutality is
worthwhile just like every other human
being because every good person
including police officers opposes police
brutality which is why it is a
statistical rarity to uncover a case in
which a police officer does something is
egregious as what happened with George
Floyd again to cite the statistics which
I know everybody doesn't like to cite
because we have to instead make the
miasmatic argument the police generally
across the nation are engaged in
brutality and violence the the number of
unarmed black men shot by the police
according to The Washington Post last
year was 9 and that is a statistical
anomaly that does not mean that not that
every one of those cases was not a
tragedy I don't know the details of all
those cases but I'm sure that most of
them were tragedy doesn't mean the case
of Brianna Taylor isn't a travesty it is
an absolute travesty Brianna Taylor case
person well I'm not sure why Brianna
Taylor isn't the isn't the face of this
movement as opposed to George Floyd
other than the Brianna Taylor thing
wasn't caught on tape in the Brianna
Taylor thing to me and George Floyd
thing is egregious it's an atrocity the
Brianna Taylor thing is even worse I
mean the Brianna Taylor thing she was
sleeping in her own apartment and the
police offered a no-knock war and then
shot her in her bed you know that one is
like beyond that one is beyond and and
how those officers are still not under
arrest is absolutely beyond me I mean
it's crazy but put that aside what we
have now reached is the point in the
narrative where hangers-on have started
to take control of the narrative and you
can sense it you can sense that the
hangers on the people who were not at
the core of the protest and we're also
not the radicals who were always using
protests in order to push ridiculous
agendas that most Americans didn't want
the people who in other words had been
sitting
aside those people have jumped into the
fray in order to virtue signal and the
best indicator that it causes over is
when the Hollywood actors jump in
because now we've reached the point in
Seinfeld where we are in the ribbon
bullies episode I don't remember this
episode of Seinfeld it's a great episode
of Seinfeld where Kramer is walking
along the street and there's an AIDS
March and somebody gives him an AIDS
ribbon and he doesn't want to wear the
AIDS ribbon and so everybody starts
yelling at him then they start basically
beating him up because he won't wear the
AIDS ribbon that is the point that we
have reached in the in the black lives
matters movement because right now the
question isn't whether you care about
black lads you do I mean Kramer I assume
cared about AIDS the question is whether
you are willing to virtue signal and how
hard you're willing to virtue signal and
then once you virtue signal what else
can we get out of you okay and so
Hollywood has decided to jump in full
scale and make mockeries of themselves
so I'm old enough to remember when two
weeks ago Madonna I had her son dancing
in the kitchen to Michael Jackson we
were all mocking this like Oh racism
solved guys racism solve but now all of
Hollywood is engaged in the Madonna son
dancing to Michael Jackson in the
kitchen that's what we now have so
yesterday a bunch of very woke and and
very self-righteous Hollywood
celebrities including people like Aaron
Paul and Kristen Bell and Sarah Paulson
did a video for I take responsibility
organ which they announced that they
were taking responsibility for all the
world's sins then like the Jesus of this
moment they're going to take
responsibility of all the world's sins
on their shoulder and and then they will
rectify the imbalances in the universe
by doing so now I will say that for a
bunch of actors they don't do very good
performances except for Aaron Paul who
really dials this up to 11 like Eagle at
the end of this video it goes full Jesse
Pinkman by the end of this video
Aaron Paul is basically screaming at the
camera about police brutality and how
the police are murdering people and
Julianne Moore suggests that that black
people are being slaughtered in the
streets by police I mean it really is
some very solid stuff from Hollywood but
you can tell that for a lot of these
stars the things become a grift simply
because they're doing what they are
doing and I don't doubt the sincerity of
their feeling about black people dying
because every decent person feels that I
do doubt the sincerity of putting out a
video where they take responsibility for
all the world's sins and suggest that
they will never ever ever tell a bad
joke ever again ah they won't tell a bad
joke ever again or uh they won't stand
by and watch a police brutality happen
where they
members of the PD were they standing by
were they like dare at the George Floyd
killing because I don't remember Sarah
Paulson there I feel like that would've
been a big news story of Sarah Paulsen
had been there and just been standing by
doing nothing in any case here was the
video from these Hollywood stars
pledging that they take responsibility
no be fair about this when you're a
Hollywood starting you sake I take
responsibility what you're actually
saying is I do not take responsibility
for any of this stuff
what you're actually saying is everybody
else is the bad guy having the good guy
and the way you can tell I'm the good
guy is because of my performative
atonement my performative atonement
means I'm not like those other white
people and this this video is like all
white people the the entire videos bunch
of white people saying I take
responsibility which really means I
don't take responsibility I'm one of the
good ones guys I'm a good one I'm the
kind of person who would plywood up my
window and then spray paint black lives
matter on it right that's the kind of
person these actors are don't please
don't break into my mansion because the
fact is that I am with you I am with you
all the way up until the point when it
actually comes to sacrificing my part
for a person of color then I'm not so
into it but like right now in front of
this camera I know the reason this is
important guys is because you can see
again what began as a as a sincere
outpouring of upset over George Floyd
and police brutality has become for so
many people an opportunity to virtue
signal on behalf of their own sort of
political cadre and their insider e
Hollywood cronies here is this video
yesterday it's astonishingly bad I take
responsibility I take responsibility I
take responsibility I take
responsibility for every unchecked
moment for every time it was easier to
ignore than to call it up for what it
was every not so funny joke every unfair
stereotype every blatant injustice no
matter how big or small every time I
remain silent
every time I explained away police
brutality okay stop it for a second I
mean every time you explain why police
brutality who among these actors was
like oh man that Rodney King thing that
was great
who what are you talking about what are
you talking that also I'm really looking
forward to the to the professional cut
of all the various jokes that these
various actors have told in the course
of their careers that would that
apparently they don't
like anymore I recognize that one of the
people who's being most sincere is
Justin throughout Justin Theroux wrote
Tropic Thunder in which Robert Downey
jr. plays a black man and tells nothing
but racist stereotypical jokes for two
hours okay so I'm gonna go with you guys
didn't care about any of this stuff
until you decided that it was worthwhile
virtue signaling about it the sincerity
of me here without makeup and I haven't
shaved you either that means that I am
totally sincere guys now I'm not gonna
stop this video until we get to Aaron
Paul my colleague Matt Walsh he had a
great line about this yesterday he
called it the I take responsibility
challenge how long can you get through
this video before you have to turn it
off but we have to we have to continue
this video until we at least get to
Aaron Paul's oscar-worthy performance as
very concerned white person every time I
explained away police brutality or
turned a blind eye I take responsibility
black people are being slaughtered in
the streets killed in their own homes
these are our brothers and sisters our
friends in there for a second I'm sorry
that that one actually I have to stop
just to rebut it ok the notion that
black people are being slaughtered in
their own homes by the cops is just
nonsense it's just nonsense
it is not true the fact is that the
police shot last year according to the
Washington Post 1004 people about 250 of
them were black nearly all of them were
armed and resisting the police black
people are not being slaughtered on mass
by white people in their beds the
dickship helped put out a comedy special
there she fells a comedian he can
obviously say what he wants he's a
comedian right he can make whatever
whatever jokes he wants I'm not in favor
of censorship of comedians or chiding
them for the sorts of language they use
or something like that that's comedy but
Dave Chappelle makes a serious point in
which he suggests that anyone who
survives this nightmare is a hero and I
just think to myself ok there are 42
million black Americans 41 million nine
hundred and ninety two thousand five
hundred of them were not shot last year
and of the remaining 7,500 who were shot
the vast majority were killed by other
black people in the black community
because nearly all murder in the United
States is intra-racial meant interracial
and only 250 were shot by the cops at
all and only nine were shot unarmed so
that does not sound like everyday black
people are under existential threat in
the United States because they clearly
are not I mean they've compels a very
very wealthy person LeBron James very
very wealthy person has done very very
well for himself
good for them is America everybody
should have the opportunity to do really
well for themselves which is why we all
stand against police brutality but this
notion that black people are being
slaughtered on mass is so a historical
and by the way degrading to history to
history's actual evils I mean you want
to talk about the mistreatment of black
people you don't have to go all that far
back in American history to talk about
mass mistreatment of black people to
compare today's black experience to the
black experience of 1960 with legalized
segregation and Jim Crow and
miscegenation laws what a comparative
slavery is utterly asinine and to take
that crap from Julianne Moore who's
whiter than this piece of paper right
here is beyond me anyway here is we
finally get to Aaron Paul Oscar winner
Aaron Paul in his in his finest
performance and killer cops must be
prosecuted they are murderers we can
turn the tide it is time to take
responsibility all-out hate step up and
take action I realized why they cast
Aaron Paul as Jesse Pinkman because he
actually is Jesse Pinkman
he's just Jesse Pinkman like there is no
other Aaron Paul it's not like he was
putting it on when he was doing he
really dials that spinal tap 11 there
for Aaron Paul okay so the point of this
is not that this is important the point
is that it is frivolous frivolously
unimportant and we have reached the
point of frivolous unimportance in this
debate we have remember this things
started off as how do we enact police
reform so as to quash police brutality
how do we do that has anybody talked
about any of that like in the last week
in the last week and a half my Congress
was pushing the bill does anyone know
what was in that bill does anyone care
the answer of course is no the media are
covered with other narratives with other
narratives and the problem for the press
and the problem for the left is that
once you broaden out the narrative from
Americans need to care about kill black
people which we all do to we're gonna
tear down statues of George Washington
and Thomas Jefferson and set up
autonomous zones in Seattle Americans
like you know what I'm out once you move
from we all ought to care about black
people being victimized by police
brutality to every white person is
guilty of systemic racism in this
country and you must kneel and you must
atone and you must put out a corporate
statement or we're gonna boycott you
Americans like you know what done well
no we're out we're out because you have
now moved beyond the point of the
rationale we are not gonna wear the
ribbon just because you say that we're
supposed to wear the ribbon we may agree
with the cause but we are not going to
be forced into
Hollywood hostage videos right this is
not something that we are into and you
can see the narrative turning because
the left always goes too far they can't
just say here's our wrong how do we work
to correct it because that might be too
unifying they refuse to be specific
instead you're supposed to swallow this
entire a narrative hook line and sinker
and I don't think that most Americans
are willing to swallow the narrative
that black people are systemically put
upon by police in the United States and
at threat of violence every single day
or that all white people in the United
States are responsible for the
subjugation of black people which is why
there is inequality between groups I
don't think most Americans believe that
because it isn't true isn't factually
true everyone get some more of this in
just one second first let us talk about
the best Father's Day gift you can give
I'm talking about steak Omaha Steaks Oh
Omaha actually sent me some kosher
steaks I know I'm special they are
incredible they are delicious and let me
tell you if I didn't keep kosher I would
be all over Omaha Steaks like all the
time because Omaha Steaks this is this
is great stuff they age that means that
it is tender and it is juicy it is
hand-carved aged at least 21 days for
tenderness and flavor here's what you
get when you go to Omaha Steaks calm and
enter the code Shapiro into the search
bar you say 55% on the gift dad will
love for $79.99 here's what you get for
naturally lean top sirloin steaks
hand-carved aged at least 21 days for
tenderness and flavor for premium
boneless chicken breasts for a gourmet
jumbo Franks and kielbasa sausages a
package of savory all beef meatballs for
perfectly browned potatoes au gratin
for made from scratch caramel apple
tartlets and an Omaha Steaks signature
seasoning packet dad gets all of that
plus the free pound of steak cut bacon
that's an amazing gift shipped directly
to dad's store in time for Father's Day
for $79.99 it's not gonna get better
than that makes me wish I didn't keep
kosher sometimes this Father's Day sends
add that gifts he really wants go to
Omaha Steaks com type Shapiro in the
search bar say 55% has a great deal when
you send the summer sizzle pack for
$79.99 and get free steak cut bacon with
your order don't wait head on over to
Omaha Steaks com type Shapiro in the
search bar to order that summer sizzle
pack for Father's Day today again Omaha
Steaks that concept Shapiro in the
search bar go check them out right now
okay so as I say the narrative has now
been broadened out it's been broadened
out and so now we're gonna battle over
Confederate statues we're gonna bad all
over Confederate flags now in the past
this has happened before too and I think
that there's a good argument to be made
as to whether cities ought to leave up
Confederate statues the argument against
is every time your black person you walk
by a Confederate statue go oh yeah that
person wanted to enslave grandma like
that's an evil person why is there a
statue of an evil person that taxpayers
are paying to upkeep I think that's a
fair argument I do okay then there's the
counter-argument the counter-argument is
made by Condoleezza Rice and I kind of
agree with this one more and that is
it's important to leave up monuments of
bad people so that specifically we can
point to our kids and say guys you need
to know American history in American
history there are a group of people who
wanted to enslave your great-grandmother
all right as a Jew I want outfits to
stand
I want monuments to human cruelty to
stand I think it's very important that
monuments to human cruelty stand
specifically because it reminds us that
human beings are capable of such cruelty
it reminds us of the darkness inherent
in the human heart so I get the counts
of the arguments and I get the counter
arguments but the notion that this is
linked to quote-unquote ongoing police
brutality and systemic racism is a
different question because now what
you're basically suggesting is that the
very presence of these statues is the
rationale for inequality between black
and white outcomes in the United States
and when you broaden this out to okay if
you agree with the second argument or if
you think that you know history is worth
preserving just because history is
history then that must be because you
are inherently racist this happens after
the mass shooting at the horrible mass
shooting in Charleston at the black
historic church there's this attempt to
take down Confederate flags there's an
attempt to take down statues my point
was not that these are not worthy causes
they may in fact be worthy causes I'm
not a fan of the Confederate flag right
I think the Confederate flag stood for
the a rebellion against the United
States on behalf of slavery so I'm not a
fan of the Confederate flag I'm also not
a fan of suggesting that everybody who
has a Confederate flag on the back of
their truck is somehow in favor of
slavery or the Confederacy because the
flag was not removed for 160 years and
for a lot of people at morphed in
meaning like to understand that the
Confederate flag or the Confederate
statues means something different to
different groups of people you do have
to actually talk to those groups of
people and I think that both meanings
are perfectly understandable and both
meetings are perfectly legitimate
meaning that if you're again if you're a
black person you see the Confederate
flag you say that is a flag that was
flown on behalf of a would-be country to
enslave my ancestors and that would want
me enslave today a hundred percent right
100 percent right and then you're a
southern white guy and your grandfather
had that flag when he was fight
the Battle of the Bulge which there were
tanks that flew the competitive flag at
the Battle of the Bulge because it stood
for regional pride that didn't morph
beyond its original meaning so to
suggest tacitly that everybody who's
flying the Confederate flag is
responsible for the killing of George
Floyd or something or that America writ
large is the Confederate flag and not
the American flag or that the American
flag is like the Confederate flag which
is why people are kneeling for the
American flag oh that is wrong
and once you broaden out these arguments
once you take this from the realm of
what can we do policy wise in order to
rectify problems - let's do a full-scale
rethinking and revision of American
history let's do a full-scale rethink of
the heart of the American people
let's indict people who have nothing to
do with the death of George Floyd
because they have a symbol on their car
then Americans are gonna start to balk
and by the way there's no limiting
principle here because it turns out that
for a lot of folks on the Left this does
not stop
with even statues I don't like like
Confederate statues or like the
Confederate flag right it doesn't stop
with that for the people on the hard
left it stops with George Washington it
stops with Thomas Jefferson it stops of
Christopher Columbus it stops with
anybody who represents Western
civilization or American civilization
because it turns out history is filled
with flawed people right we build
monuments to people who do incredible
things that's typically what you do now
a lot of monuments should be taken down
because people didn't do incredible
things get it alright fine fair you vote
to do it you don't go out and protest
and drag them down okay because this is
still a democratic country it's still
democratic republic but I get it but to
take down every monument to a person who
lived in a historical time that you did
not live in who did a bad thing and then
she used that as an excuse to take down
the statue that's beyond now you're
basically saying that all of history is
evil except for this present moment and
if you don't jump on our side of this
political issue in this present moment
you stand with the bad thing this person
did so if you like George Washington
what you actually are celebrating is the
faculty held slaves not the fact that he
was the father of the country and if you
like Thomas Jefferson you're not
celebrating the Declaration of indepen
independence or the Louisiana Purchase
you're celebrating what he did to Sally
Hemings you're celebrating what he did
to Sally Hemings and that is a lie it's
a lie most Americans don't celebrate
that sort of stuff when I say most I
mean virtually all so we're gonna get to
the attack on history because there is
some irony to this like Nancy Pelosi
wants to take down a bunch of statues at
the
capital her dad actually put up a statue
to a to a Confederate - I believe
Stonewall Jackson in 1948 in Baltimore
sheshe has refused calls - to to talk
about that we'll get to more of this in
just one second first let's talk about
the fact that two out of three dudes
will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
the best way to prevent hair loss do
something about it while you still have
hair left you just have to go to the
doctor's office for your hair loss
prescription well now thanks to Keats
you can visit a doctor online and get
hair loss medication delivered directly
to your home they make it easy they
deliver your medication every three
months so you can say goodbye to
pharmacy checkout lines and awkward
doctor's visits prevention is key
because once the hair is gone it's
basically gone I mean the chances of you
regrowing it fairly low so go get it
taken care of right now you'll want to
keep your hair and you got to do it
early right because once it starts going
it's basically a one-way ticket - to mr.
clean land find out why keeps has more
five-star reviews than any of its
competitors and nearly 100,000 men trust
Cube's for their hair loss prevention
medication keeps treatments start at
just 10 bucks a month plus for a limited
time you get your first month for free
I've been using keeps myself because
male pattern baldness does run in my
family you should use it - if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to keeps calm slash men's
receive your first month of treatment
for free that is ke EPS calm slash man
keeps calm slash pen go check them out
right now and again and get your first
month of treatment for free when you use
keeps calm slash them ok so there's all
of this argument now over the over these
historical statues and again it is not
restricted to Confederate statues the
Winston Churchill statue in London has
now been boarded up there's a picture
today of it in in an actual metal case
like an opaque metal case you can't see
it anymore it's been boarded up statues
of Christopher Columbus are being torn
down now you don't have to think that
Christopher Columbus was a wonderful guy
to acknowledge that him crossing several
thousand miles of ocean without any clue
where he was going and bringing the
possibility of Western civilization's
the Western Hemisphere was a good thing
overall for the world even if it was a
very bad thing for the natives he
encountered hey that doesn't mean that
Christopher Columbus is a wonderful guy
or that you today would have done the
same things that Christopher Columbus
did but to rip him out of history and
then say all the bad things he did in
history are unique to Christopher
Columbus which is obviously untrue
and then to suggest that the real reason
you're taking him down is because all of
history is filled with bad people that's
not what people are doing right what
they're actually suggesting when they
tear down the Christopher Columbus
statue is the same thing Howard Zinn did
at the beginning of his people's history
of the United States suggesting that the
vicious evil of Christopher Columbus was
not the treatment of the natives per se
it was the fact that he brought
capitalism to the Western to the Western
Hemisphere that's really what Howard
Zinn says right because Christopher
Columbus was a bad evil Western
civilization guy he should be torn down
and then if Western civilization had
never come to the Western Hemisphere it
would have been better for the world
generally which is an extraordinarily
charitable read of both history as well
as the as well as all circumstances on
the north and south american continents
prior to the arrival of Western
civilization the sort of ideal of
Rousseau Ian Rousseau Ian paradise
before Western has ever hit is is just
not factually true Steven Pinker has a
whole section in his book about the fact
that you know all societies experience
violence all societies experience
tribalism all societies that we know of
experience heavy levels of warfare and
conquering Columbus was not unique in
that what made Western civilization
unique is that Western civilization
eventually turned against that that's
what makes Western civilization unique
and so Nancy Pelosi is joining that she
says she wants to take down statues at
the Capitol she wants to take down
Confederate statues at the Capitol now
the goal of this is really to suggest
that anybody who doesn't want to take
down Confederate statue stands with the
Confederacy know maybe you just like
American history and you think it's very
very important to discuss the fact that
many of the people who founded the
Confederacy actually were high-ranking
members I mean really high-ranking
members of the American government until
they founded the Confederacy and so you
have to recognize the evil that is
present in every human heart and in
American history like you want to create
a what's amazing right now is that when
it comes to American history the left
has basically suggested not a
well-rounded American history a
well-rounded version of American history
basically they've suggested the only
book you need to read about American
history as Howard Zinn Katy tur from
MSNBC tweeted this yesterday she tweeted
you should just go read Howard Zinn
which is a stupid ideas a stupid
person's idea of a smart history book
it's a people's history of the United
States well you should do is you should
read a people's history of the United
States and you should also read a
traditional American history and you
should recognize that a people's history
is propagandistic nonsense in
I mean he literally says that the
fascism that America defeated in World
War two in his book was in was was then
taken into the bones of the United
States this is something that Howard
Zinn says in his book I mean Howard Zinn
is a garbage historian there's a great
book called two bunking Howard Zinn that
is well worth the raid you should go
check that out okay but the left loves
this thing so this is about rethink from
American history and this is why I say
the narrative is beginning to turn the
left always cannot stop at the point
they have to move into their broader
points and their broader point is
something people generally do not agree
with even even Andrew Cuomo the governor
of New York is saying like no this is
not a thing we're not taking down
Christopher Columbus statues here was a
here's Andrew Cuomo man's a Democrat but
he still understands that Christopher
Columbus is a meaningful figure in the
history of America and in the history of
Western civilization here's here is
Andrew Cuomo the curse of a Columbus
statue represents in in some ways the
italian-american legacy in this country
and the italian-american contribution in
this country I understand the feelings
about Christopher Columbus and some of
his acts which nobody would support but
the statue was has come to represent and
signify appreciation for the
italian-american contribution to New
York so on that for that reason I
supported me so he is right but he's
also you know missing the point which is
that the real reason it's good that
Christopher Columbus came to the Western
Hemisphere is because it is good that
Western civilization came to the Western
Hemisphere
even if Christopher Columbus did very
very bad things right you can
acknowledge both of those things at once
that's called an actual well-rounded
version of history okay but the left
doesn't want that well-rounded version
of history instead they want you to buy
into the idea that the reason that there
is inequality between black and white in
the United States is because of the evil
inherent in Christopher Columbus the
evil inherent sin George Washington the
evil inherent in Thomas Jefferson and
this is why Tom cotton got up yesterday
the senator from Arkansas in the Senate
and he said you you guys are talking
about tearing down the Washington
Monument well what what what are you
even talking about now now you're
talking about the roots of the country
being systemically evil we're not going
to do that that's not a thing
here's senator cotton where does this
cancel culture take us what is the
logical conclusion what is
the end of the canceled culture I will
tell you what it is it is right here in
this city Washington the District of
Columbia that's where it will end if we
don't put an end to the madness nail
just up the mall is the Washington
Monument are we gonna tear the
Washington Monument down oh we under
renamed it the obelisk of wotus hey so
first of all great name for garage man
obelisk of Volquez but but with that
said he's not wrong and this is why this
this whole the whole movement which
started off as a unity movement is
starting to lose steam because the
minute that you diversify the message
into things like America is was always
will be historically marred by its own
DNA I mean all white people are racist
inherently in their bones and must atone
like this sort of stuff does not have a
shelf life it doesn't it has it has a
radioactive half-life for most human
beings and that's what you're starting
to see happening right now because it
turns out that when you are something
for something universally good people
generally around your side when you
broaden that out to indict people for
things they didn't do not so much we're
gonna get some more of this in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that now is a terrible time to go to the
post office
I mean why would you go to the post
office generally anyway when you can
stay at home and just use stamps.com
you're sending a lot of packages these
days but you don't want to wait in line
at the post office right now head on
over to stamps calm you can print
postage on demand skip the lines and the
crowds at the post office never a better
time to skip the lines and crowds then
right now plus you can actually save
some money with discounts you can't even
get at the post office and as if that
wasn't enough stamps calm is also
offering UPS services with discounts up
to 62 percent no UPS residential
surcharges here at the daily where we
have been using stamps.com to save time
and money
since 2017 which is why we have a
successful business stamps.com brings
all the services of the Postal Service
directly to your computer you can use
your computer and print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter any package
any class of mail anywhere you want to
send it and once your mail is ready you
just leave it for the mail carrier and
schedule a free package pick up drop it
in the mailbox when you're done and like
I said with stamps that come huge
discounts five cents off every
first-class stamp up to 62 percent off
shipping rates right now my listeners
got a special offer it includes a four
week trial plus free postage and digital
scale no long-term commitment head on
over to stamps com
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage type in Shapiro that stamps
comm enter Shapiro again stamps comm
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and enter Shapiro okay so
as I say the the worse this gets the
more ribbon signaling this becomes the
more you are bullied into wearing the
ribbon the less people are going to be
into it and and this is taken some
pretty radical ramifications so four
examines expected to buy into is really
the question what are Americans expected
to buy into because we're all on board
with police brutality is bad here are
some reforms we might make we were all
pretty much into that but then it turned
out that that wasn't the agenda it turns
out the agenda was much broader and
deeper than that and that's a problem
and so people like David Shore good
example according to Jonathan Chait
writing at New York magazine David short
is a 28 year old political data analyst
and social democrat who worked for
President Obama's re-election campaign
on May 28th short tweeted out a short
summary of a paper by Princeton
professor Omar wasa the research
compiled by Wausau analyzed public
opinion in the 1960s and found that
violent and nonviolent protest tactics
had contradictory effects sure synopsis
was straightforward quote post MLK
assassination race riots reduced
Democratic vote share in surrounding
cities by 2 percent which was enough to
tip the 1968 election to Nixon
nonviolent protests increased
Democratic vote mainly by in court
encouraging warm elite discourse and
media coverage so he's making a simple
point nonviolent protest good violin
protest bad he was fired he was fired re
through hilio Wesler the founder of open
field the democratic canvassing app
replied this take his tone-deaf removes
responsibility for the press turnout
from the 68th party and reeks of anti
blackness David choice at the mechanism
for the papers and turnout it's violence
driving news coverage that makes people
vote Republican the author does a great
job explaining his research here employs
it and clients on civis analytics
complained that Shores tweet threatened
their safety the next day Shaw
apologized for even tweeting out this
point citizen analytics undertook a
review of the episode and then Shore was
fired and then Shore was fired so in
other words if you say that nonviolent
protests are better than violent
protests they will fire you now it
doesn't matter that you were a
Democratic Socialist who backed Barack
Obama they will fire you for that or
let's say
I'm old enough remember like a week ago
when the message from Democrats is that
most cops were good there were just some
bad cops and that that didn't mean there
wasn't systemic problem but most cops
were good I'm old enough to remember
when Barack Obama said that Barack Obama
said in his speech that cops were
generally doing good job that cops were
generally good people trying their best
well now we've reached the point where
institutions are being bullied into not
allowing the cops to pee and poo on
their premises ok Berkeley School of
Music
put out a statement that they were
deeply sorry for allowing Boston police
officers to use the school's restrooms
following the downtown protest in the
mate on may 31st in the wake of the
killing of George Floyd the school says
it will not happen again
Berkeley president Roger brown chief
financial officer Mac Heisey and Public
Safety Chief David ransom said the
college had heard expressions of anger
and betrayal from their community after
they allowed Boston police officers
access to poop to the back Bay's schools
restrooms Boston police of course have
jurisdictions over roads and other
public spaces around our campus but not
inside our buildings Berkeley officials
said the decision to allow them into our
facilities was ours this was not a
formal decision by the institution but
an informal one made on the spot we
understand that many of our members of
our community feel betrayed we are
deeply sorry for the impact has had on
our community and for perpetuating
feelings of oppression silencing and
marginalization wear the ribbon wear the
ribbon will pay the price and that
ribbon means you are a racist
the ribbon doesn't mean you're anti
racism it means acknowledging that you
are a racist acknowledging that
everything you do is racist
acknowledging that if you allow a cop to
poop in your bathroom that you are in
favor of police brutality acknowledge or
pay the price and then you wonder why
steam seems to be running out just a
little bit here because it turns out
that when you go too far people are not
super into it now I'm gonna bring you
some more examples of things going too
far and then you'll see that the
Democrats are dealing to change the
narrative so the narrative for the last
couple of weeks was America is deeply
and systemically racist America is evil
America is filled with police brutality
and on the first message there are some
fairly good response I mean Americans
were like okay we're also against police
brutality and also we would like to see
black people treated better in the
United States because yeah that's great
black people should be treated better in
the United States and everybody was on
board and the Democrats basically got
what they wanted which was to polarize
the debate around president Trump and to
suggest that all Republicans are racist
they wanted politically and now they're
out Democrats have moved on notice what
the media are covering today
the media today are not covering these
protests anymore the media have moved
back to Cove in 19 but then the
narrative has turned and now it's
Trump's bad cuz he's gonna kill you with
covin 19 again right that's it that so
was Trump is bad because he's killing
with covin 19 then it was it's so
important to fight racism you should go
out in the streets and infect each other
on mass that's how important it is and
now we're back to Trump is killing you
of kovin 19 why because the narrative
ran out of steam for the Democrats
because they changed the narrative if
they just stuck with the unifying
narrative it wouldn't be in a democratic
narrative see Democrats had to do two
things one find a popular narrative
which they did to try to harness that
narrative in pursuit of their own
political goals which they sort of did
and then the narrative ran away from
them and now they are moving back to
Copa 19 we're gonna explain why in just
one second
first let us talk about to say the fact
that you know these days like every day
you might be worried about your safety
you might be worried about what's going
on outside your front door you may be
worried about somebody sneezing on a
package and leaving it in your rail
backs right there are lots of reasons to
worry about what goes on on your
property for me the biggest thing is I
got to keep track of my kids my kids
have running wild in the middle of this
lockdown we're home more than usual
these days that does not mean you don't
need to know what's going on on your
property it probably means you need to
know what's going on more often than
ever this is why you need a ring ring
gives you protection in every corner
video doorbells let you answer the door
and check in on your home anytime keep
an eye on your doorstep speak to
delivery people when you can't come to
the door without door security cameras
you can check in on every part of your
house and never miss a moment smart
lighting brightens up blind spots make
sure you always come home to a brightly
lit house full home security systems
give you everything you need to protect
your family pets and property I've been
using ring for years at my property
makes me feel safer it makes my wife
feel safer got a special offer on the
ring welcome kit when you go to ring
calm slash been that welcome kit
includes the ringing video doorbell 3
and the chime Pro that's all you need to
start building custom security for your
home today go check them out right now
at ring Netcom slash pen again that's
ring.com
slash pen to get that welcome kit
including you ring up video doorbell 3
and the chime probably at a special
offer on that when you go to ring.com
slash bet okay we're going to get into
how the narrative got away from the
democrats and how they basically are
taking their ball and going home now
that's essentially what's happening you
can see it with with the democrats
they're shifting the narrative from
trump is bad because he's racist to
trump his bad cuz he's racist cuz Cova
that's that's the that's the new tactic
and that's because once you have moved
from police brutality as bad to all cops
are bad and all white people are bad and
also how about we set up an autonomous
zone in Seattle most Americans like you
know what I'm out I'm out you can see it
happening in real time
most Americans are only gonna be bullied
into the woke ribbon wearing for as long
as they sort of agree with the
underlying message but when the
underlying message changes so does
American willingness to go along with it
we'll get to that in a second first and
is that glorious time of the week when I
give a shout-out to a daily wire member
today it is Darth Raider on Twitter who
understands the timing is everything in
this picture two little boys are
enjoying a rainy day in a large puddle
with the help of the world's most elite
beverage vessels the caption reads no
sooner did we receive our to left his
tears tumblers in the mail and left his
tears started pouring from the sky I
don't know what we would have done
without them hashtag leftist here
somewhere those are some cute kids right
there my goodness cuties 2020 has been
an unbelievably insane year you should
become a member just like Darth Raider
did go check out everything that we've
got over at Daley wire.com right now we
have a reader's pass offer for you if
you're a political junkie set on getting
actual information get a reader's pass
today from daily wear calm you get
access to exclusive op-eds from us your
podcast hosts our guest writers as well
as in-depth analysis from daily wire
reporters on top of robber breaking news
the membership tier is already a bargain
at 3 bucks a month if you join today you
get your first month for 99 cents which
is a great deal you also get access to
our mobile app you receive push
notifications for breaking news and
special content as well as joining the
community of daily where members
actively commenting and discussing our
content with each other she can be part
of our of our crowd which is fun that
mobile ad free access to all of the
daily wired news exclusive op-eds all
our podcasts on mobile app available for
the low low price of $1.00 best of all
your dollars are getting you the news
you need without the leftist spin so
head on over to daily wire.com slash
subscribe and join today also I think
that the last book I wrote right side of
history was a very important book I
think that the most important book I've
written for the time we are in is how to
destroy America in three easy steps it's
already an Amazon bestseller six weeks
out from publication you should go
pre-order it now it is describing
exactly what is going on in the country
and explaining how to about it well we
were watching in real time is the
destruction of the history of the
country the destruction of the
philosophy of the country the
destruction of our key fundamental
rights we are watching all that happen I
explained why in the book and how to
stop that how to rebut it
the arguments are bad in favor of it go
check out my book how to destroy America
in three easy steps I think it's deeply
important and I think you'll enjoy it as
well go pre-order to that right now we
have it over at Daley wire.com slash Ben
you can also check it out over at Amazon
or wherever else books are pre sold
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the United States
[Music]
so people that this movement has gone
too far because again the movement has
had ramifications the people are
expected to swallow that they originally
were not up for everybody was up for
stop the police brutality everybody was
up for let's take a look at the
statistics and try to figure out how we
can mitigate problems in the United
States everybody was up for that you
know people were not up for autonomous
zones in the middle of Seattle so the
media have been trying to cram this
narrative down earth rose I mean the
media have really been trying to suggest
that all that looting and rioting that
was a figment of your imagination
no longer existed this way this was the
narrative seriously from the media for a
week why is Fox News still covering bad
things happening in the United States
everything is great everything is great
you remember that time they were
breaking into the Foot Locker down the
street that was that was not a thing it
didn't happen it was gone figment of
your imagination you don't need the cops
and though in the words of the the first
lady of New York City the the wife of
Bill DeBlasio she said that New York
City would be a nirvana without the
police and so the media duly tried to
make America into a Nirvana without the
police there's only one problem it is
not in nirvana it's a hellscape so over
in Seattle they've set up Chas she has
the worst name for a republic ever there
a public of Chas the state of chad's man
which sounds like a smooth a smooth jazz
show on 92.7 the wave at 2:00 a.m.
welcome to the Republic with Chas we're
gonna play some Winston Marsalis now I'm
the Republic of chad's in any case the
Republic of Chance is not nearly that
mellow or that cool the Republic of Chad
is actually a terrible terrible place
the Seattle Police Chief who happens to
be a person of color said leaving was
not our decision like we were we were
forced to abandon this part of the city
by the mayor met Jenny Durkin and we
were not into it because actually it has
some pretty bad ramifications she's not
our choice weren't up for it you should
know leaving the precinct was not my
decision
you fought for days to protect it I
asked you to stand on that line day in
and day out to be pelted with
projectiles to be screamed at threatened
and in some cases hurt then to have a
change of course nearly two weeks in it
seems like an insult to you in our
community ultimately the sea
had other plans for the building and
relented to severe public pressure I
mean when the Seattle PD chief who is a
black woman is that they're ripping and
the mayor Jenny Durkin and saying like
you're you're just terrible at your job
you may think things have gone wrong the
media are trying to take cover for this
Seattle police chief also said by the
way there's crimes going on in there
like it's tripled our 9/11 one time you
call 9-1-1 from inside that zone we
cannot get in right it is making it
impossible for us to do our job here she
was yesterday explaining our number one
response times have tripled in the area
they've gone from just over five minutes
to about 18 minutes rapes robberies and
all sorts of violent accident have been
occurring in the area they were not able
to get to so it is not right for us not
to be able to deploy our officers here
okay that is Seattle Police Chief Carmen
batt saying like there's crime going on
in there and we can't do anything about
it
meanwhile mayor Jenny's irken like
because Trump attacked us and Trump said
like this has to stop
the Democrats are reflexively defending
the full takeover of six city blocks in
the middle of Seattle where lawlessness
is running rampant as a block party
here's idiot mayor Jenny Durkin she
compared the Republic of chad's to a
block party choose a block party it's
just like the Summer of Love out there
except for you know the armed bands who
are roaming and threatening people with
baseball bats the thing that is actually
happening is we'll see here's the mayor
a comparing chasse to a block party I
think it has been described by the
president others as what it is not it is
not a armed anti-shah militia no-go zone
we've had blocks of Seattle and Capitol
Hill shut down every summer for
everything from block party to pride
this is really not that much of an
operational challenge but we want to
make sure that the businesses and
residents feel safe and will will
continue to move that forward so I love
that the police chief is like yeah it's
an operational challenge we can't get in
and mayor's think it's not an
operational challenge it's fine it's
fine
meanwhile governor Inslee yesterday he
said he knew nothing about the Republic
of Chas it was it was a figment of his
imagination just such a bad name like
you could use anything and you come up
with the republic of chance the People's
Republic of jazz anyway
governor Inslee tweeted out
well we will not allow our threats of
military violence against Washingtonians
coming from the White House u.s.
military serves to protect Americans not
the fragility of an insecure president
so you're defending a military to a
paramilitary takeover of six city blocks
with barricades set up and people's IDs
being checked and the big threat is
Trump saying that he's gonna restore the
rights of people who live inside that
zone I mean they'll defend anything when
I say that the narratives gotten away
from folks on the left this is what I
mean if you're now asking most Americans
to swallow hold the notion that they
themselves are implicitly racist that
you have to allow City blasts to be
taken over in the name of woken Asst
they were gonna tear down the Washington
Monument
then we're gonna shut off the pipi rooms
to all the cops then we're going to
throw out on the job anybody who
mentions a fact they were gonna boycott
anybody who says a true thing most
Americans are gonna be like you know
what it's not livable no the answer is
no the nerve has gotten away from the
Democrats because they embolden the most
radical point-of-view in their party and
decided instead of centralizing around a
unity message and most Americans could
get behind they would instead go for the
most radical message and just continue
to follow that path it's pretty
incredible now the media they haven't
given up on this the media are still
trying to pretend it the Republic of
Chas is going really well now number one
I have some evidence that Republic of
Chaz's not all not really going all that
well a few of you it is it is sure
hilarity to watch the developments in
the developing nation of Chas it's
pretty spectacular they they set up a
farming co-op I think that they may may
need some Republicans to set up this
farm for them because I think that their
garden is is a fail it looks like they
just bought some topsoil and then they
literally just poured it on grass and
then they didn't even dig holes for the
plants it looks like they just stuck the
plants directly on top of the sod and
also they planted like five things so
that well that would be enough to feed
one person a vegan sour salad
one month from now I have a feeling they
may have some severe food shortages and
their public of chas
I like that they've called it the
autonomous zone because they put up a
sign yesterday of all the things that
they need in their public of Chas and it
is a very very large list
they said supplies needed I'm looking at
this sign close more pants male t-shirts
belts
ice the good kind cigarettes and
lighters ice the good kind I get it like
not immigration Customs Enforcement
cigarettes and lighters well I didn't
know that was the thing lanterns
flashlights head lamps portable solar
chargers Gatorade backpacks tense body
attract phone minutes cards cuz you got
to have the disposable phones guys by
loschen Wow no no what's going on in the
Republican chance shoes betting in
comforters zip ties folding chairs
laundry bags personal fans body wash
disinfectant and sunglasses it doesn't
sound like they're very autonomous
doesn't sound super autonomous to me got
to be honest with you
also we've been hearing that it's very
peaceful right it's block party
according to the mayor well the the
occupiers forced out a journalist so a
person went in there with a camera and
one of the marks of a fully free zone is
that you should be able to go in there
and film things but apparently the
people who run the place are not so hot
on that so here's some video of a person
basically being put upon by the by the
new police force in the republic of chaz
remember this was done to abolish the
police so meet the new police much worse
than the old police here they are going
after a person filming them and they're
very large man following him shouting
and chanting
you don't matter this mf'er remember
that time that people said black lives
matter and all lives matter are not
actually mutually exclusive right black
lives matter just means that people
don't pay attention to black lives
that's why we say black lives matter
well now you have a person overtly
saying that some lives actually don't
matter as long as we disagree with them
raised nobody who saying black lives
don't matter but you got this guy and
then crowd chanting whose life doesn't
matter this guy's life doesn't matter
because he is filming in the republic of
chance things are going great in the
developing nation of chess meanwhile
governance in the republic of Chazz has
fallen on hard times yesterday hilarious
tape broke of them having a struggle
session they were trying to figure out
what's coming next in the internecine
squabbles between the Bolsheviks in the
Mensheviks
over in the republic of Chazz now Julio
Rosa got this tape he's a reporter for
Town Hall calm he was on our radio show
yesterday and here was some of the
leadership of the republic of chance
trying to figure out what they do that
and do next apparently there's an
argument whether they're supposed to
disband whether they try to take over
the neighboring regions of Shaz or
whether they just move the republic of
chaz to a different area because
apparently they have picked all of the
all of the shelves clean here is the
hair of the speaker's trying to figure
out what exactly they're supposed to be
doing
[Music]
your words and your pain then go ahead
can right get right with you right
complain
do what you gotta do but taking a bunch
of folks up there to riot and do all
that what does that oh okay
well done everything going very very
well over here so here's the problem for
Democrats because they've gone so far
with this thing because they're now to
the point of defending all this is just
a normal sort of block party and by the
way the media are fully defending it the
best clip of the day was yesterday a CNN
reporter was in the area and started
talk about how peaceful this wasn't then
in the middle of the clip acknowledges
oh yeah there are people who are armed
walking around over here and threatening
people and there are people who are
trying to break up his segment on
Anderson Cooper the media are just they
are an extension CNN MSNBC they are just
the the media wing of the Democratic
Party at this point so they are willing
to repeat any narrative put forth by the
Democratic infrastructure here's the CNN
reporter things go wrong for him in this
segment if in fact there is going to be
federal officers or federal law
enforcement come to this area it is not
going to be a pretty situation these
people have made it clear that unless
there's some kind of major reform and
remember they want to see this police
department defunded or even abolished
short of some type of major concession
they're not going to leave voluntarily
and we should point out that Washington
is an open carry state and no doubt some
of these protesters are armed Anderson
so you have to worry about the potential
for bloodshed the potential for violence
if in fact they're gonna try to remove
these people by force but it's a
peaceful it's a piece of a block party
everybody it's a peaceful block party
whoops whoops CNN lets the cat out of
the bag okay so here's the problem for
the Democrats this gives Trump a pretty
good talking point do you like when
large swaths of your city are turned
over to roving bands of Communists is
this like your favorite thing are you
into it are you into the idea that
statues that the Thomas Jefferson
Memorial and the and the Washington
Monument these things ought to be torn
down are you warm to that idea are you
warm to the idea that even if you don't
like Confederate statues well
we need our roaming bands of nineteen
year olds tearing down statutes and
apparently killing each other in the
process if the person whose skull was
basically crushed by a falling statue
the other day and we do have a voting
republic here in the United States like
that's a thing that we do
okay so Democrats are having to turn
away from this narrative in turns fork
over nineteen they're gonna consolidate
their gains and they're going to try and
make the racial argument and then
they're going to move on and that's
what's happening the media have moved
back toward COBIT nineteen so the thing
is that the entire here's the thing for
the Democrats the entire campaign has to
be run by narrative cuz it can't be run
on his candidate Joe Biden is not in a
live person anymore I'm sad to report
the the demise of Joe Biden
r.i.p I mean like if you watch him he is
he is not sentient anymore okay this is
not a this is not a rip on people as
they get older he is not what he once
was and anybody who pretends that he is
what he wants was his line to you I mean
here's a clip of Joe Biden yesterday
basically getting what he says I'm bored
with my own talk here he's I'm talking I
just get bored with myself yeah join the
club man I'm beginning to get bored by
my uncle taught you know the rapidly
rising that it's it's over it's over for
Joe Biden right so they're left with
just the narrative and the narrative is
that Donald Trump is a racist and so we
reached the the actual end point for
many of these Democrats the point was
never to solve police brutality the
point for many Democrats not the
protesters many of the protesters are
sincere the point for top-level
Democrats was to channel the anger into
ingred Trump that's it for a lot of
Democrats that's what this was about
that's why they brought in the narrative
and then Neal not because they are
trying to solve the problem of police
brutality but because they want to drive
the broader narrative that America is a
systemically racist place and that
systemic racism is represented by Donald
Trump so here was Joe Biden doing this
routine about Trump on race this
president from the very beginning
from the moment he came down the
escalator and his golden building when
he started off saying I am going to see
to it that we get rid of all those
Mexican rapists just thinking in defeat
hate you can only make it hide now when
you give it oxygen when the president
speaks no matter how good or bad he is
people listen and when he speaks and
gives credibility to these racist
language ok so again this is the
narrative the Democrats have tried to
drive the problem is that then there
they've gotten what they want out of
their narrative right they'll continue
to push it right Kamala Harris was very
likely going to be Biden's VP pick even
after she called him a racist for
opposing force bussing Kamla Harris
yesterday she suggested that Donald
Trump throwing a rally in in Tulsa which
is happening June 19th which is known as
Juneteenth which was the day
historically speaking when the
Emancipation Proclamation was finally
read in Texas which was the final state
to receive news of the Emancipation
Proclamation by the way Juneteenth
should in fact be a national holiday
right if we're gonna talk about like
symbolic changes that'd be great
Juneteenth should be a national holiday
Frederick Douglass should be on our
nation's currency right these are things
that I've been saying for years I mean
this is nothing new but Pamela Harris
suggests that because Trump is speaking
in Tulsa Oklahoma which was a place in
the United States on June 19th this
means to wink and nod at white
supremacist because of course one of the
great race riots in American history was
a white on black race riot in 1921 in
Tulsa Oklahoma I'm sure that's exactly
what was going through Trump's head he
probably was going Trump known for his
for his granular granular attention to
American history probably thought to
himself what could I do to signal to
white supremacist I know I'm gonna go to
Tulsa for a understudied like really
most Americans don't know about the
Tulsa Race Riot unless they just watched
Watchmen right on HBO that's the first
many Americans knew about that which is
a travesty most Americans should know
about that but you think Trump was like
that little-known historical or are
under known historical situation I'm
gonna go there I'm gonna signal to white
supremacist and do it on Juneteenth
another under known historical
circumstance or do you think maybe
somebody just scheduled them an event
and he's going there so but this is the
narrative right the problem is that at
this point because the narrative has
moved away from the Democrats because
they have because they've gotten what
they want out of it they've gotten the
poll numbers out of it they've gotten to
dump Trump
on numbers because of his response to
this whole thing and now because things
are getting worse not better now because
there are no policy platforms on the
page that are actually going to result
in any political benefits of them see
here's the thing if they get a wide
bipartisan bill to ban chokeholds
doesn't benefit Democrats at all and
they're not going to do anything like
racial reparations because it's too
divisive and most Americans don't like
them so instead they go to the narrative
the narrative is Trump is bad they got
what they wanted so now they're just
moving on to Cova 19 again which is
gonna be a hard press because again
they're the ones who said to everybody
go out and protest in the streets
without masks so Tom Perez is doing this
we're back to you covering Cove it 19 as
a crisis which by the way is spooking
the stock market and it is the media
coverage spooking the stock market
because the reality is we are not
actually seeing spikes in these states
what we are seeing is a slow and gradual
rise in states where this thing never
went away right this isn't a second wave
this is a first wave because it turns
out that when you lock down all you do
is prevent the first way which is
something I've been talking about for a
long time when you relieve lockdown then
people are going to get infected but Tom
Perez is now back to suggesting that
Trump is killing black people with his
club in nineteen response here's Tom
Perez the DNC chair Donald Trump rather
than battling bigotry wants to battle
Twitter rather than bringing us together
he wants to continue to drive us apart
what has he done to black people in
America he has resulted he has killed
them in some places because of his
failed response to coronavirus the
unemployment rate joblessness
hopelessness that he is trying to stoke
the differences between joe biden and
donald trump couldn't be clearer so this
is back to the cove in nineteen
narratives so I hope that everybody
enjoyed two weeks of the of the George
Floyd narrative
I hope they enjoyed it because it turned
out that the Democrats weren't sincere
about actually wanting change all they
wanted to do was benefit from unrest
again not the protesters Democratic
politicians but now we're back to Copa
19 guys and the narrative is over
everybody back to the regular day jobs
of suggesting that Donald Trump is
killing people because of ending
lockdowns even while Democratic
governors are ending lockdowns alrighty
well we have reached the end of today's
show but we will be back here later
today with two additional hours of
content otherwise I've been saying every
weekend try not to burn down the country
please like one of these weekends could
we do this just one otherwise enjoy your
life stay away from other people wear a
mask i'm ben shapiro this is the bench
bureau show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling assistant
director Pavel why douse key technical
producer austin stevens playback and
media operated by Nick Sheehan associate
producer Katie Swinton edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh show it's not
just another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen